Indian couple what's
up huh that's your
sister both yall just lonely together
huh are there any other Indians here
maybe we could just do a double match
right here you are you with this
girl she's your sister too hey hey hey I
think this might work out yo y'all need
to hang out after the show have your
parents call his parents I know they
know each other are y'all from Vegas are
y'all from Vegas they for sure know each
other they for sure know each other what
do you do for a living sir physician's
assistant what about you miss what do
you do you're a pharmacist same through
saying y'all that's the same we both try
to be doctors for two years in so I
can't do this D to the same Destiny
y'all this is meant to be I think what
about you sir what do you do you're a
pharmacist hey if you're a nurse this
is really
perfect you are a
nurse